good afternoon and welcome to this the
launch of our aya season of giving and
our day of service this is really
exciting for us because the aya has now
entered the digital age for all of you
social networking gurus out there this
may be
uh mundane but for us here this is an
event as we come closer to the 21st
century so this is an exciting
opportunity for us i'm here with lisa
chapman the national chair of our day of
service and with elisa masterson our
staff person who is supporting all of
you and i want to give a big shout out
to darcy jelani scott mike sarah all of
you are you out there we don't know how
many are tuning into this i can only
guess
this is uh
an important occasion for us because uh
not only are we taking the opportunity
to give a shout out to all of you that
would
participate in this day of service but
we'd like to get your feedback we'd like
to know what ideas you have what we can
do to better improve this opportunity
for our alumni to serve you know there
hasn't been an activity in the past six
years of all of our new ay initiatives
that has drawn as many young alumni that
have drawn as many of our alumni from
our graduate and professional schools to
this family that we call the aya
it's entirely encouraging and inspiring
that so many new
alumni would come together in all of
these opportunities that are staged
around the world to give back to our
communities
we thought a lot in the past two years
about our success metrics here at the
aya and what makes this place work
and when i'm on the road i often ask our
yale clubs what is your success metric
and they will often come back to me and
say well it's the number of events that
we stage or perhaps it's the number of
volunteers or participants that come to
our events or maybe and i grind my nails
on the chalkboard it's the number of
dues paying members that we have
and while those might be important
measures of what it is that we do
they're inputs after all they're not
outputs the real success metric might be
this
if yale's mission is to educate and
train world leaders
then wouldn't the success metric for any
local yale club be
how are our communities changed how are
our communities better because yale
world leaders
live there
and while we might express that in many
different ways through our activities
where we invite faculty members out to
yale clubs where we have social
gatherings around important events in
the life of this university
after all i think the real measurement
is how do we as alumni
influence the communities around us
and in so doing give back to the
communities that served us and nurtured
us so well
you know yale's mission
as defined in its charter of 1701 was to
instruct youth in service to church and
state
this tradition of service is part of our
dna it's a very important part of who we
are and how we would define
our alumni community to the rest of the
world
and every school child i think knows the
famous words of nathan hale who said i
have but one life to lose for my country
but i am convinced that his more
powerful words are carved on the base of
harkness tower right above the trumbull
room in the brantford courtyard and
those are those words are i wish
to be useful
if you read the whole quote it's all
about giving back and that any service
to society that would be so useful would
be noble
i think it is in that tradition that we
launch again another day of service
i might add days of service we're often
asked how can we change the world in one
day
often asked by our ivy league peers who
are trying to convince us that one day
might not be enough but i would remind
them that it is days of service and we
have so many clubs shared interest
groups and even our yale college classes
that engage in service projects
throughout the year this one particular
day of service gives us a chance to
rally the troops provide an opportunity
to focus on what is really important to
us and to focus on what values we might
want to convey
from one generation to the next because
of who we are as an alumni group
well one of those values is the fact
that these programs are volunteer driven
and managed
i can say honestly that the groundswell
of support the inspiration from these
programs came from volunteers and i
i can't think of a more enthusiastic
volunteer actually than the woman
sitting next to me lisa chapman class of
81 at the school of management
i don't know where your pom-poms are and
where the cheerleading outfit is but i
think we should design one for the day
of service because you are truly an
ambassador and someone i think
who not only
is enthusiastic and excited and
passionate about these programs but you
live this
and i've seen that through all of your
participation not only the day service
but on the aoa board of governors in
your participation with our alumni
service corps and all the other projects
so i would like to introduce you to our
star volunteer lisa chapman mark thank
you so much
and i'm very honored and touched by your
kind words but it's not about me i'm
just the alumni volunteer chair it's
really about the people we serve and i'm
glad to be in this position and honored
to be to be the chair for the for this
year lisa you're not running for office
no but i want to talk about data service
opportunity and what the data service
program is is for all yale alumni family
and friends
around the globe to make a difference in
their communities where they live and
work it could be helping veterans
re-enter the workforce it could be
helping children with mentoring or
career opportunities or even cleaning a
park all these little pieces make a huge
difference where we live and work in our
communities
and you know people ask me they often
ask me lisa why do you serve why do you
do this
and i have to tell you to be honest
i'm so inspired by the people i've met
over the last four years being involved
with the day of service program from
being a site coordinator in new jersey
to regional director in new jersey and
now the to the chair
um the yale members the people who work
in the sites the yale alumni leaders
i've met through all the various uh
worlds that the yale leaders are busy in
um have inspired me but really what's
really truly inspired me are the people
we serve when you're working with
people who've had incredible challenges
in their lives who share their stories
with you you're working hand in hand
with them and you're sharing their sense
of joy that's what truly inspires me and
i can't say enough about the
opportunities you have given me at the
aya to be of service to yale and to the
communities at large
um i want to say for the program uh we
we need your participation out there
everybody who's tuning in now and on the
on the video uh feedbacks on the posted
on our day of service
the day of service website on facebook
on twitter which you'll see all this we
need your participation we need your
impact and we have tools to help you do
that we have projects in a box how to
create a day of service project we have
tools how to use social media how to
make a video it's all there for you to
use and i want to highlight we have our
date is monday is saturday
may
10th
2014. come join us the yale day of
service and you can like us on our yale
day of service facebook page you connect
to us through our twitter yale day
service and you can also post any photos
from day of service on instagram yale
day of service so please join us we need
you and we want to make a difference
to 2014. thank you mark post post post
get the pictures out there get the
tweets out there let everybody know what
you're doing
while our programs are volunteer driven
i have to add that it is a wonderful
partnership with the aoa staff and that
we
help manage these programs to the best
of our ability and to the the best of
our resources and uh i'd like to
introduce elisa masterson who's been
with the away how many years have you
been at the aya 23 23 years and you've
worked in the class group you worked in
the club group maybe not the class group
i did you did you work in the club
and now
22 years later you come to this day of
service and um i am thankful for the
passion and the excitement that you
bring to this from the staff perspective
i mean i really it's it's it's fun to
see staff get as excited as our
volunteers and these wonderful projects
and you're going to share with us some
of the how to's and the logistics of the
data service i am very excited about
working with this program it's one of
the few programs that we have at the aya
that really crosses all different areas
of aya work we work with clubs and
classes with shared interest groups
there are amazing partnerships that come
together when the yale women work with
the yale club of chicago work with the
latino alumni association for a really
empowering site there's a lot of great
opportunities for our alumni groups to
work together and create these great
service opportunities um the other thing
i wanted to mention in terms of
logistics while our date is may 10th
we do have a lot of flexibility there
are dates other dates that might work
better for your community or community
that you're working in and we're very
happy to have other service dates for
projects around the day of service we'll
still take care of listing them and
registering people for those sites
so if you're wondering many of you on
this broadcast i think have been
involved with the day of service as site
coordinators some of you have been
participants some of you may want to be
site coordinators and as lisa referenced
there are lots of resources available
and the first thing i want to point you
to is our newly redesigned website
www.yaledayofservice.org it's been
totally overhauled it's a much better
experience to tell the stories of the
day of service you'll see all our
previous videos there you can find
photos of day of service sites it is not
yet live for registration because our
sites are not live we'll talk about the
timeline in just a moment but there is
something at the top you can click on
the organizers toolbox and in the
toolbox are a variety of resources from
a timeline to how to's that lisa was
referencing sample communication sample
materials so there are many resources
there to help folks who want to organize
a day of service site in addition lisa
herself and myself as staff are always
available to help folks and and also
this amazing network of regional
directors that we have on the contact us
page you'll see a listing of all the
regional directors the country the world
actually has been broken into various
sections and there's a leader volunteer
who's there can help be a resource for
you in many ways to create day of
service sites
so where we are in the timeline right
now is we have just
relaunched this new day of service
website there'll be an email going out
to all alumni for whom we have email
addresses on thursday or friday of this
week
drawing people to the website and
announcing the date so people can get it
on their calendars nice and early the
may 10th date
and in addition at that point we'll be
opening the site collection process so
for the next month we'll be collecting
information on sites we'll be processing
them in the database that's behind the
day of service website and then in early
march we'll send another email to all
alumni announcing that we're going live
and that registration is open and at
that point floods of people will start
registering for the day of service and
we'll have an amazing successful program
once again
our goal many of you know that we have
hit a bit of a plateau we have about 3
500 people who participate every year
but this year we're really looking to
push it out and get to 5 000 5 thousand
volunteers and we want your help to do
that so if you're watching this
broadcast and you're interested in
getting involved more involved than
you've been
please take a moment to go to the
website reach out to any of us and we'll
be here to help you
i also want to invite you to go ahead
and submit questions to us mark and lisa
and i will shortly be taking some
questions there's an address a gmail
account address that's on your screen if
you want to email those questions we'll
be able to take them live here very
shortly
but i just want to take a moment to
thank all of you because your
involvement in this program is what
makes it work and the fact that you're
here watching today lets us know that
you are as committed to this program as
we are and we feel very fortunate that
yale alumni are willing to give back and
to really make a difference where they
live
lisa you mentioned something at the
start of your comments that i want to
underscore
i think people need to realize that we
are not an alumni association we are an
association of associations we are a
community of communities
we are 75 yale college classes we are
187 regional yale clubs we are more than
100 almost 150 shared interest groups
tell me just briefly the kind of
projects that work best
are those where these groups
collaborate with each other and partner
on specific projects that they don't
have to feel that they have to own
individual projects but they can work
together can you describe some of the
sites that work best i'd be glad to do
that mark um what's wonderful is we have
a tremendous collaboration starting with
the clubs we have clubs working with
alumni we have shared interest groups we
have groups of alumni in different parts
of the country
who actually work together so what for
example this last project i worked on
was in belmar new jersey which was a
town hard hit by hurricane sandy it was
co-spondered by co-sponsored by many of
the uh shared interest groups yale women
uh the yale uh hispanic group the black
america
black american yale alumni association
uh numerous clubs and they all got
together we had 45 people in belmar new
jersey jersey tutoring and mentoring
young hispanic children we also had a
heavy population of
hispanic parents and our alumni group
broke off and helped the parents in our
educational system so that's just one
example you know when you're working
with a child and you see a smile on
their face and you just you just melt as
a volunteer just right then and there
and that's why we all want to serve and
and come back again and again every year
but throughout the country in chicago
they work with the refugees in san
francisco they work in chinatown
we work with collaborations with all
sorts of community groups as well as
yale groups and i think what's great
about the program
is we're all getting out of our comfort
zones we're all doing things we've never
done before with people we've never met
and you go and want any of these data
service projects and i inspire all of
you out there listening to step up and
if you've never been on a site or you
haven't coordinated one
it's a blast and you you find yourself
doing things beyond your wildest dreams
for others and it's in collaboration and
working as a team
so while we blast emails here
advertising the day of service um i
uh i wanted to also mention that the
power of this communication often rests
within these various networks these
alumni associations to communicate it on
their own so that if there's a
collaboration with the yale women and
the yale club of princeton and the
yellow black alumni association or the
yellow mcgorris they can all pump the
word out to their individual networks so
the power of that communication and the
overlapping message is what drives many
people to the site
if i
wanted to be a site leader
what do i do how do i get started so the
first thing that i would do is get in
touch with your local club president uh
find out if there's already a club
coordinator for your club
or your regional director
and then go to the website and go to the
organizers toolbox it gives you the
timeline it gives you all the resources
that are available
the other big piece of it of course is
finding a partner organization to work
with where you want to do your service
site now in many cases our alumni are on
boards of organizations they've been
involved with organizations in the past
sometimes they've heard about the
organizations in the local paper if you
need suggestions we also have site
selection
suggestions on the website in the
organizers toolbox so there are many
many ways to get involved i might also
suggest that uh we don't normally lack
for ideas of where we can serve i think
if you're going to be a site leader
we hope that you have friends family
yale colleagues in the area that you
might bring to the project as well i
mean we're counting on you to build
attendance and to build
a team around these particular project
sites uh we're not lacking for where to
go and how we might serve uh what we
really want to do is get the word out to
other yale alumni so that they might
want to show up yeah i would just like
to add mark that the best the best
projects are run by those people with
the strongest passions people are driven
to make a difference it's what they
believe in it's what they see in their
local neighborhoods it could be cleaning
up a park it could be it could be
working in a soup kitchen it could be
helping with a clothing drive it's
whatever makes them
want to work and make a difference and
that their enthusiasm and their
engagement
is volumes
so let me ask you this is this only
about yale alumni what if i want to
invite another university group or what
if i want to invite other community
partners we definitely we definitely
encourage that um we if yale can be a
catalyst for bringing more people in to
make changes in their local communities
all the better so we absolutely reach
out and we do partnerships and the other
thing that i think i want to mention
that we find it's very important is the
ill day of service is a great way to
share these values with your family so
your children your grandchildren it's a
wonderful opportunity for alumni to work
side by side with other alumni other
alumni families our environmental
projects tend to be great opportunities
for alumni to come together with their
kids to share these values and to have a
good time together making a difference i
i it can't go without mentioning that
this has developed into one of our
strongest family programs
i'm amazed for example at the elementary
service corps that of the 175 people we
sent to
ghana africa last year over 30
were children aged between 10 and 17.
it is a real occasion for families to
discuss
what really matters in life what are the
values that we would wish to convey
through an institution like yale and how
we would convey those to the communities
around us it's an extraordinary
opportunity yeah what's exciting also is
every year a third of our participants
are brand new so these are yale alumni
who for reasons um weren't able to
participate and come back to yale and
come back to alumni engagement through
the day of service program and what i
said what i've seen over four years is
remarkable someone may start once with a
park or a river or some cleanup site and
then they progressively get larger and
larger into very large meaningful
and important habitat for humanity
or the art project in harlem the music
groups they're they're they beyond they
go beyond by the day the weekly and the
experience they have they also become
sustainable programs many of the day of
service programs are not just the one
day
but they become monthly or they become
weekly or they become whatever is
inspired by them and that would be part
of our goal here right we don't want to
be one-off opportunities absolutely we
hope that these one-day projects might
develop into monthly projects or even
weekly projects exactly and even
national projects yeah yeah and we love
the partnership idea i mean it's one
thing to have a bunch of yalies show up
it's another thing to have them actually
partner with the organizations and roll
up their sleeves and help
contribute to that organization
throughout throughout the year
i have another question that's come up
on the screen i hope you're all sending
in questions uh
the name uh from
i can't read the name rob greeley from
boston oh rob greenlee from boston hey
rob how are you rob's our yale club
president in the in yo boston when can
we send out the website link to our club
members so the the um actual broadcast
email is going to be going out in the
next couple days but you should feel
free you can give them advanced notice
it's live it's ready to go send it now
and i'd like to send it often
and i'd like to add we are very active
on the yale day of service facebook page
we're very active on twitter and now
instagram and probably some other social
media outlets so
watch us like us on facebook respond you
can post your own messages your own
photos we want to hear from you talk we
have a facebook page yes and who can
post on that anybody can post anybody
can post on it we want we want
participants to post last year we had
many many people post their photographs
and comments about their own personal
experiences okay so of a
to alumni of a certain age
i won't
make a hazard guess as to what that age
threshold might be
how do you find this facebook page okay
you go to
facebook.com and you type in yale day of
service and it pops up that's all you
have to do it's that simple and you can
contribute right there you can see that
and what we want to hear we want to hear
your stories no we want you to like it
right well we want people to like it
once they like it then it becomes part
of their automatic news feed um but you
go on and you post your own story and
and what you did last year in your day
of service project and what it meant to
you and maybe a photograph or two
and that's also a new feature of our new
our redesigned day of service website uh
there is a share your experience link
where you can go on you can upload
photos again
share your thoughts and your experiences
and we'll be able to share those on the
website so if you go now there's a great
photo gallery of site pictures from last
year which we hadn't really had a medium
for showing uh and so that's a great
opportunity facebook is fabulous but as
it's sort of chronological so this way
we can aggregate all of the experiences
and have them available alisa tell us
what's in the toolbox for site
coordinators what can they expect to
find there so the toolbox starts from
very basic things like a timeline and it
goes uh further and includes all kinds
of sample communications it includes how
to look for a site it includes how to
post your site it includes how to
promote your site how to communicate
with your club president how to
communicate with local alumni uh all the
way down to appreciation certificates
that you can give to the organization
that you partnered with and the alumni
who participated so there's a whole
variety of things how do you social
media step-by-step guide that lisa
worked with our new social media yale
organization s-a-y social at yale to
create um their how to do a video so
there's all kinds of information there
that really would should give you
everything you need and if there's
something that's missing let us know and
we'll if you're asking the question
probably someone else has it too and
we'll be sure to get it up there i i'd
like to also uh suggest that the videos
and the pictures that you may take are
not only important for communicating the
message
uh to others as a thank you immediate
after the day of service or even
advertising for the next day or the
continuing
aspect of the program but we also use
these videos to inspire alumni
at large during our away assembly every
november so if you have an inspirational
piece please share it with us because we
will work this into our materials to
share throughout the year not just
immediately after that day of service
uh mark i'd like to add one important
part about this social media we want
everybody to be engaged in social media
not just me as chair or the regional
director or the site coordinator anybody
who goes on the day of service sites
they can
put post a comment or post a photograph
it's really everybody has a role here
it's not a top down leadership really
the world is flat here and we're all
contributing what we can and we want to
hear from everyone who participates even
from a child we had we had children in
one of our one of our sites in
california and the children were doing
the photographs for taking the
photographs and posting them so we might
have had somebody that just joined us i
have a question here does my project
have to happen on may 10th
no it can happen anytime that works for
you and the non-profit or the agency or
the the park or wherever you're working
with it's up to you to figure out what
the best timing is we often have
projects on sundays we have them during
the week
in new jersey we had a project which
sponsored a
multi-world language competition it was
on a monday monday but i think i think
it's a great opportunity for people to
really open their perspectives about
when they can do these sites though i
also think that there is some sense of
um
some sense of real participation when
everyone realizes all around the world
on that day somewhere there are people
doing community service in the name of
yale so we absolutely encourage people
to do it any day they want but also we'd
love to have those sites on the tenth as
well so tell us some of the places
outside the u.s where they've had
significant days of service sure so um
we have a great site in nigeria um the
in china what are we doing in nigeria do
you know well i'm not sure if ola bc
who's the person who's there is doing
the same project this year but it's been
a outreach women's outreach um we have
beijing
um we have puerto rico we have um i know
ghana the yale club there club of ghana
is going to be doing this year yeah
service corps and our international
regional directors are working really
hard to develop some new sites the yield
club of switzerland does an amazing job
the yale club of england did a really
incredible mentoring program last year
with high school students
um there's all kinds of really amazing
things happening around the world we've
had some turkey we've had last year's
project with turkey we paired with uh
partnered with one of the world fellows
one of her organization and uh the
service project was done through through
her organization so that's another great
partnership with our our world fellow
leaders around the country around the
world so why do you think yali's
come back every year
to participate in this oh
you do it once you you have to come back
there's no
there's no no here once you once you go
on any of these sites throughout
throughout the world and you work with
yalies hand in hand and other community
groups and other co-sponsors
working with people who
benefit it could be painting a building
working on art projects doing movies
making food whatever it is
you are so touched by the experience
personally it's incredibly fun it's
incredibly exhilarating and you want to
do it again
and again and again and that's what we
want
well you know it's only one day but it's
really a beginning and these projects
have then become lifelong passions for
people yeah and i think it's it's also
encountered upon our site coordinators
to ensure that all of our volunteers
have a meaningful experience and a good
time there
i'd like to think that we could always
rely on our volunteer partners
to provide the kind of program services
that our alumni would find to be a
meaningful use of their time but
sometimes our psych coordinators have to
fill in and they have to be the leaders
that we all know they are to make sure
that alumni have a great experience and
will come back
year after year
um
so is there any advice for post yale day
of service activities i mean what
happens when it's done here what what
can we expect our regional directors
what can we expect our site coordinators
to do after the day of service
well we hope that they'll do um follow
up with the participants and thank them
for their involvement and i think is key
yes yes thank them for that we can't
thank people enough for their engagement
here and ideally provide them an
opportunity to continue to engage
through service another one of the new
features of our day of service website
is the opportunity for clubs to post
ongoing opportunities for participation
so that ones that aren't part of the
yale day of service brand that are not
registered for through our website but
are ongoing can be listed now and so
alumni who come to our website who are
relocating or are interested in service
can look and see what's going on in
their area so we invite all of our clubs
and our club presidents and our regional
directors people who are involved to
post uh there's a online form that you
fill out and we can post ongoing
opportunities there on the website if
you have a really successful
site i would hope that you would go back
to your yale club board and say hey
maybe we should continue yes and not
just next year but on a weekly or a
monthly basis and in fact one of our
overarching strategies here is to
develop national partnerships
i know we've made
some
forward progress with
big brothers and sisters um i know that
we've looked at a number of other uh
partners such as habitat for humanity or
uh
j.a so
put your thinking caps on and if you
find yourself at a project site that is
particularly exciting where the
partnering organization is
enthusiastically supportive of our
volunteers in the yale family getting
involved think about how we may develop
that into uh not just a regional
partnership but a national partnership
i'm absolutely i was just going to add
that you know we're often role models to
people we don't even know and what i
found with the day of service program
and for people who participate
the after what they do next is they
they're so inspired by their personal
experience they want to do more they
they join the board of the non-profit
they they want to expand it during
monthly programs so
it's very much getting the word out and
the personal experience is the driver uh
often site coordinators in work within
their local media they write up their
their experience so they share it
locally and the word goes out and yale
you know it's it's really not about yale
for yale it's yale it's yale alumni
getting together and sharing their
experience and communicating the world
and being leaders
we have an email question from peter
butterfield are your principal tools for
increasing turnout the new site and
social media
or are there other tools as well well we
always have the uh the main sort of
blasts that come from new haven uh that
go to all alumni there are usually three
or four during the cycle
of the day of service progress
and we will continue to do those but as
mark alluded to earlier we definitely
rely on local communications both from
individuals and from clubs or other
organizations and now we do have this
powerful new tool social media so we're
not relying on any one thing it's really
multiple angles people need to hear
about it from different things but
really one of the most important and
most powerful ways to do it is for
individuals to be those advocates to be
the ambassadors and say hey i'm doing
this great thing why don't you come do
it i mean we had one year we had a woman
it was her birthday and she invited all
of her friends as their birthday her
birthday celebration they did a day of
service project together and then they
went out to lunch um so there are lots
of creative ways that we can bring folks
together around the day of service and
promote the day of service and it's
really um there are many channels for
that well and let me just add um what we
do every week
is we have a conference call with 30
regional directors around the world half
an hour call
we're going to start for two weeks
and have it for a couple of weeks
and then break up and do it weekly as we
get closer to the last couple of months
for a day of service but that's an
opportunity for 30 regional directors to
share stories best practices ideas
issues concerns opportunities and that
we do that on a regular basis and that
helps
really run the program
so we're at the end of the half hour and
i'd like to
leave everyone with this thought
as you all know
a significant milestone in the life of
this university was the inauguration of
peter salovey as president and uh i can
say that uh
while we had a fabulous economist and
rick levin who propelled us into the
next century with
an amazingly strong university we now
rely on a cognitive psychologist to lead
the way and as someone in alumni
relations i can really appreciate the
fact that
peter
wrote the book on emotional intelligence
because what we do is connect with
people emotionally through opportunities
like this the day of service
the corporation and peter recently went
through an exercise where they were
trying to identify those values that are
most important to us
as a university community and if you
read peter's book you would know that he
talks a lot about joy and joyfulness and
that in the workplace we don't often
celebrate that as much as we do anger or
power or
the kind of negative emotions that
force people to work rather than inspire
them to work
and i can say this this
day of service
is one of our opportunities to celebrate
joy
um i think uh it's it's uh no mystery
that people feel good about volunteering
and
this is an opportunity for us as a
family to recognize that the most
important thing that we can do is give
back to the communities that that gave
to us and this day of service uh has
become our opportunity to bring yalies
together from all around the globe
to celebrate joy
thank you for participating today i hope
we provided you with some uh insights i
hope we perhaps explained a few things
that might not have been clear and we
look forward to periodic updates and
keeping everybody inspired and up to
date on
day of service developments thank you
everybody
you